a guy could wake up this morning you
know and be like I see these kids
out there making all that money
my kid needs surgery I'm going out here
and get some of it you know and uh
and go get the money you know so I had
to break it down to him like that and
that's the way he wrote the brief up to
the appeals court
you know that a guy can't become a
career criminal in one day you know
there's no way you're a career criminal
and you only committed crime one day
it's not possible and and and the way I
when I found out the way the law read is
that it's a continuous criminal spree so
a spree could go for a day it could go
for 10 years
but it's still one spree
on a hell of a spree but the way you
word it that's true yeah that is
completely true that's what it is a
continuous criminal spree it's not
interrupted now if it gets interrupted
by jail now you know you're in the wrong
now your career criminal going back a
gag